S
CNN NEWSROOM WITH ROSEMARY
CHURCH.
>> ETHIOPIA HAS FOR DECADES,
BEEN THE BENEFICIARY OF A U.S.
GOVERNMENT TRADE AGREEMENT,
GRANTING HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OF AVAILABLE ACCESS
TO U.S. MARKETS.
ALLOWING ETHIOPIAN AIRLINES, IN
RECENT YEARS, TO BUILD A GLOBAL
FLEET, AND BECOME ONE OF THE
WORLD'S LEADING AIRLINES.
FOR BOTH THE U.S. AND ETHIOPIA,
THIS RELATIONSHIP MATTERS.
BUT FOR ALMOST A YEAR, NOW
CONFLICT HAS RAGED IN
ETHIOPIA'S TIGRAY REGION.
NUMEROUS SENIOR INVESTIGATIONS
HAVE UNCOVERED EVIDENCE OF CNN
GOVERNMENT ATROCITIES.
WE --
CARGO CARRIERS HAVE BEEN
SHUTTLING WEAPONS BETWEEN
ETHIOPIA AND ERITREA AND WET
EXPERT BELIEVE MAY CONSTITUTE A
VIOLATION OF INTERNATIONAL LAW,
AND THAT TRADE AGREEMENTS WITH
THE U.S..
WE WILL >> WITH DIRECT FLIGHTS
FROM OVER 95 INTERNATIONAL
DESTINATIONS, FLY ETHIOPIAN
AIRLINES, THE NEW SPIRIT OF
AFRICA, A STAR ALLIANCE
PARTNER.
>> IF YOU OPEN AIRLINES IS
AFRICA'S PREMIER CHARACTER OF
PASSENGER AND FREIGHT.
AMONG THE REGULAR CARGO,
EVIDENCE OF SINISTER SHIPMENTS
--
CNN CAN REVEAL BASED ON AWE
DOCUMENTARY EVIDENCE AND
WITNESSES ACCOUNTS THAT IF YOU
CAN AIRLINES HAVE BEEN
TRANSPORTING WEAPONS ETHIOPIA
YOU OPEN SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
THE WAR IN ETHIOPIA THAT HAS
SEEN THOUSANDS KILLED.
ACCORDING TO AVIATION EXPERTS,
THIS WOULD CONSTITUTE A
VIOLATION OF AVIATION LAW.
AMONG THE EVIDENCE THESE STILLS
THAT WERE TAKEN ON BOARD
ETHIOPIA AIRLINES FLIGHT ET
3313, AND VERIFIED BY CNN.
IT'S THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
THIS CARGO PLANE IS BEING
LOADED BY HAND, A SLOW AND
UNORTHODOX METHOD.
BUT LOOK CLOSER.
THIS ISN'T USUAL CARGO.
INSIDE THESE BOXES ARE WEAPONS.
THEY ARE BEING LOADED ONTO THE
CIVILIAN AIRCRAFT AND
TRANSPORTED FROM ERITREA TO
ETHIOPIA.
HERE IS THE CARGO MANIFEST,
CORROBORATING THE DAY AND TIME.
NOVEMBER 8TH, 2020.
THE DATE IS SIGNIFICANT.
IT'S JUST 4 DAYS INTO THE
CONFLICT, AND MONTHS BEFORE
ERITREA OFFICIALLY ADMITS TO
BEING INVOLVED.
ETHIOPIA HAS BEEN AT WAR WITH
THE TIGRAY REGIONAL GOVERNMENT,
AT THE TIGRAY'S PEOPLE
LIBERATION'S FRONT FOR ALMOST A
YEAR.
ERITREA TO THE NORTH HAS BEGUN
ETHIOPIA GOVERNMENT ALLY
AGAINST THE REGION OF TIGRAY.
AN UNUSUAL ALLIANCE AS THE
COUNTRIES WERE PREVIOUSLY AT
WAR WITH EACH OTHER.
NOW, THEY HAVE A COMMON ENEMY,
TIGRAY.
AND THEY ARE SHARING WEAPONRY.
>> WE ARE CNN.
JOURNALISTS.
WE ARE CNN --
>> CNN HAS BEEN REPORTING ON
ATROCITIES IN ETHIOPIA SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR.
>> IF YOU WANT TO OBTAIN A CNN
TEAM, THEN THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED
NOW,
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT GOING TO THE
CAMP WILLINGLY.
>> WE TRAVEL TO TIGRAY LAST
APRIL, AND SAW FOR OURSELVES
ERITRIAN TROOPS MANNING
CHECKPOINTS WITH IMPUNITY.
WHILE THE PUKING GOVERNMENT
DENIED THE PRESENCE ON THE
GROUND.
THAT RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN IF
ETHIOPIA AND ERITREA BEGAN
MONTHS EARLIER.
IN NOVEMBER 2020, WHICH
COINCIDED WITH AN INCREASE IN
THE MOVEMENT OF WEAPONS
SHUTTLED BACK AND FORTH FROM
THE ETHIOPIAN CAPITAL TO
ERITREA.
>> IN THE SAME MONTH THERE IS
ALSO A SERIES OF MASSACRES IN
THE REGION OF TIGRAY. AN
ETHIOPIA AIRLINES EMPLOYEE
WHISTLEBLOWER SPOKE TO CNN
ABOUT HOW HE ACTUALLY HAD TO
DEAL WITH AN UNUSUAL REQUEST.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> IN VARIOUS STATEMENTS,
ETHIOPIAN AIRLINES HAS ALWAYS
ADAMANTLY DENIED CARRYING ARMS
ON PASSENGER OR CARGO PLANES.
BUT, IN ADDITION TO SPEAKING
WITH WHISTLEBLOWERS, VERIFYING
CARGO MANIFESTS AND
AUTHENTICATING STILLS, CNN HAS
OBTAINED AIRWAY BILL RECEIPTS
THAT SHOW AT LEAST 6 OCCASIONS
IN NOVEMBER, WHERE ETHIOPIAN
AIRLINES BUILT THE ETHIOPIAN
MINISTRY OF DEFENSE TO SHIP
MILITARY ITEMS, INCLUDING GUNS
AND AMMUNITION TO ERITREA.
>> IN THE END, THE SUCCESS OF
THE ETHIOPIAN AIRLINES IS
IMPORTANT AND AN IMPRESSIVE
SYMBOL OF THE LIMITLESS
POTENTIAL OF THE U.S. ETHIOPIAN
PARTNERSHIP.
>> ETHIOPIAN AIRLINES BUILT ITS
CARGO DOMINANCE IN THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT AND AMERICAN
AVIATION GIANT BOEING.
THESE NEW CNN FINDINGS,
TOGETHER WITH PREVIOUS
INVESTIGATIONS INTO ATROCITIES
COMMITTED BY ETHIOPIAN FORCES,
WOULD CONSTITUTE A VIOLATION OF
INTERNATIONAL LAW, ACCORDING TO
AVIATION EXPERTS, AND RUN
CONTRARY TO THE TERMS OF THAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT.
WHETHER THERE ARE FORCES TO THE
U.S. TO ACT AGAINST THE
ETHIOPIAN GOVERNMENT, REMAINS
TO BE SEEN.
NIMA ELBAGIR, CNN, LONDON.
RESPONDING TO CNN'S LATEST
INVESTIGATION, ETHIOPIAN
AIRLINES SAID IT COMPLIES WITH
ALL AVIATION REGULATIONS, AND
QUOTE, TO THE BEST OF ITS
KNOWLEDGE, AND ITS RECORDS, IT
HAS NOT TRANSPORTED ANY WAR
ARMAMENT, IN ANY OF ITS ROOTS,
BY ANY OF ITS AIRCRAFTS.
A U.S. TRADE SPOKESPERSON TOLD
CNN, THEY WOULD REVIEW
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE U.S.
AFRICAN GROWTH AND OPPORTUNITY
ACT NEXT YEAR, WHICH WILL BE
BASED, UPON COMPLIANCE WITH
STANDARDS THAT INCLUDE, IT HERE
IN STATE INTERNATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED WORKERS RIGHTS, RULE
OF LAW, AND HUMAN RIGHTS.
WE WELL AFTER THE ROOT VIEW,
THE U.S. TRADE REPRESENTATIVE
COULD POSSIBLY RECOMMEND, THAT
THE U.S. PRESIDENT AT OR REMOVE
CERTAIN COUNTRIES FROM A.G. OH
A BENEFICIARY COUNTRIES STATUS.
--
MANUFACTURER BOEING SAID THAT
THEY HAD NO COMMENT FOR THE
STORY, AND THE ETHIOPIAN AND
ERITREAN GOVERNMENTS DID NOT
RESPOND TO REQUESTS FOR
COMMENT.
WELL, OR EARLIER, MY COLLEAGUE
JOHN FORCE, SPOKE WITH THE
TRANSPORTATION ANALYST ABOUT
THIS.
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT WHETHER
PASSENGERS AROUND THE FLIGHTS.
WE >> WE FOUND OUT THAT BOTH
WITH --
CNN HAS NO EVIDENCE THAT
COMMERCIAL PASSENGERS WERE ON
ANY OF THE FLIGHTS CARRYING
WEAPONS HOW SIGNIFICANT IS THIS
WEAPON ABOUT WINS THE WEAPONS.
BOB >> WELL IF THERE ARE PAID
PASSENGERS ON BOARD, OR ANY
PASSENGERS ON BOARD.
IF IT IS DEAD HEADING
PASSENGERS.
AND THAT VIOLATES A NUMBER OF
LAWS.
BECAUSE AT THAT POINT IT WOULD
BE A CIVILIAN FLIGHT, A
CIVILIAN CARRIER, AND IT'S TO
GET JEWELED CAT PASSENGER
CARRIER AND OF COURSE THEY
CANNOT CARRY MUNITIONS, FOR
SUPPLIES, PRESUMABLY THEY'RE
CALLING THIS CARRYING MORE
SUPPLIES AND NOT JUST SMUGGLING
GUNS THAT IS CLEARLY A
VIOLATION >> BECAUSE THE
ETHIOPIAN GOVERNMENT, AS THE
OWNER OF WITH ETHIOPIAN
AIRLINES, IT CAN DECIDE WHETHER
OR NOT THE FLIGHT IS A CIVILIAN
FLIGHT, EVEN IF IT'S THE SAME
PLANE.
OR IF IT'S A COMMERCIAL FLIGHT,
RIGHT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
AND IN MANY COUNTRIES, THEY
HAVE THOSE KINDS OF LAWS,
INCLUDING THE UNITED STATES.
IN TERMS OF NATIONAL EMERGENCY,
THE UNITED STATES CAN DECLARE
THAT THE CIVILIAN AIRLINES
BECOME BASICALLY PART OF A AWE
FLEET TO SERVE THE COUNTRY AND
THE GOVERNMENT CAN ORDER THEM
TO BECOME PART OF THIS NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
NOW, EVERY COUNTRY HAS THEIR
OWN SET OF LAWS ETHIOPIA LAWS
MAY AWE BE VERY DIFFERENT.
AND IT'S ALSO DIFFERENT BECAUSE
THEY OWN THE AIRLINE.
THE GOVERNMENT OWNS THE
AIRLINE.
BUT MANY COUNTRIES HAVE LAWS